hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
video I'm going to answer questions from
one of my newsletter readers Julie who
is a fashion design student wants to
start her own business in the fashion
industry and doesn't have money to get
started so wanted my advice if you
should go to the bank so how she should
get the capital to start your business
so Julie Thanks for writing in first of
all with the banks usually what they're
going to look at is your personal credit
so it's a new business ideally for a
business loan they want to see that
you've been in business for three years
or more and have some kind of track
record before they'll give you money on
your business so that means everything
that you get from the bank is going to
be personally liable so if you can't pay
it they're going to come after your
house a car whatever assets you have and
it's really depending on how good a
credit score you have so if you have
really good credit then it's easy to get
money from the bank and if you don't
have great credit then you're not going
to get money from the bank for you
though I think the best thing you can do
when you're starting up a new business
is not start paying money don't start
spending money until you're making money
so it's not about how much resources you
have is about how resourceful you are so
go out there and try to make sales
before you're starting to spend money on
your business so you can design
potential clothes ideas that you have
you can go out and maybe even make one
prototype if you absolutely have to and
try to get people to buy on the sample
and the prototype go to retailers you
know maybe boutique retailers where you
can actually talk to the owner see if
they like the idea and try to get orders
just on off of your sketching you design
before going out and spend a lot of
money creating your clothes that way it
gets you closer to your customer you
have a cash flow source coming in and
you're much more likely to see if you
find that you don't really know enough
about the business yet and you really
want to make sure you have a stable
income while you're building your
business thing you can do is go work for
a company that you respect so you know
going to get a job isn't the end of the
world as long as you can learn from it
so go find a company who you want to be
like so a small fashion design house
where you can go and learn the ropes of
the business you can start your business
on the side be making money from your
job I'm
some important industry contacts to help
you when you do grow your business and
you learn as much as you can about the
actual business itself by working in
that type of company so don't get a job
just to make money get a job to actually
learn something that will help you
eventually grow your business so I
wouldn't count on the banks and summary
we encounter the banks has a good source
unless you have really good personal
credit I try to boost up my business on
the start so go try to make some sales
talk to customers talk to potential
retailers and boutique shops and get
them to make a purchase decision based
off your sketch or maybe a sample and if
you really need cash to kind of get
started then thought trying to find a
job with somebody who you respect in
your industry that you can learn a lot
from before you start your business and
then circuit business on the side so
hopefully that helps Julie if you guys
like the video please give it a thumbs
up below it's what makes me want to keep
making more of these videos for you guys
and if you have other thoughts for Julie
as well feel free to leave a comment
under the video a lot of seeing those
come in and we'll see you on the next
episode
you